le professeur bernard delbosc chef de
service à l'hôpital de besançon fait
partie des 35 ophtalmologiste qui ont
écris à emmanuel macron et à la ministre
de la santé
ils demandent un moratoire sur les
lanceurs de balles de défense
effaré par les dégâts commis par ces lbd
cette importance et la dga et du nombre
de maisons qui nous ont fait réagir en
tant que médecins spécialistes dont
l'objectif est habituellement de
préserver la vue est aussi en tant que
citoyen suite à une enquête lancée par
ces professionnels hospitaliers ont été
comptabilisés 18 cas de traumatismes
oculaires graves
les blessés ont 90 % de risque de perdre
l'usagé de leur ayant des conséquences
on tape très importante
franchement très importante sur la
personne elle même sur sa vision son
activité sociale sur son activité
professionnelle
donc si ce type d'engin à des
conséquences telles on ne peut pas ne
pas réfléchir à son utilisation la
manière de s'en servir
on se dit que c'est quand même très cher
payé la participation des manifestations
joël mathurin préfet du doubs reconnaît
que les forces de l'ordre ont utilisé
les ailes bd dans le département plus
d'une vingtaine de fois depuis le début
du mouvement principalement à besançon
et à montbéliard
selon lui les policiers avaient face à
eux des casseurs quand on passe en
violences urbaines
quand il y à des jets de projectiles
acide parpaings boules de pétanque
on est en situation de défense des
forces de l'ordre et donc dans certaines
situations dissous il ya les personnes
qu'il faut neutraliser et on arrive à
des mules traditionnel bd avec les
moyens appropriés avec professionnalisme
avec cent fois mais qu'il faut que la
force reste à la loi
outre des professionnels de santé
d'autres voix demandent l'interdiction
des ailes bd de jacques toubon le
défenseur des droits jusqu'au conseil de
l'europe